y santiago a las 8 de la tarde o la hora
local se espera que el presidente electo
joe biden se dirija a la nación en este
primer discurso lo hará acompañado de su
esposa y el baile por supuesto de su
compañero de fórmula- kamala harris y su
esposo lo harán desde este centro en
wilmington delaware en el estado vecino
a pensilvania donde nos encontramos
donde han ido anunciando estos últimos
cuatro días
[Música]
aquí ante el cielo nea como veis
continúa la fiesta esto va cada vez
aumentando más porque presionarían no ha
sido nada fácil de conseguir son 20
votos que se han peleado hasta el último
aumento primero por esas dos veces que
se han trasladado hasta aquí antes de
piso después del martes de elecciones el
equipo legal de donald trump acusando
que impide ofrecer van ya se están
haciendo un recuento con fraude era algo
que no tenía ningún tipo de pruebas
además la corte suprema justo ayer tipo
que permitía que iba le iba a dar el ok
a esa petición que había hecho el
partido republicano de separar los votos
por correo que habían llegado más tarde
en el día 3 pero con fecha anterior al
día 3 de noviembre para que fueran
contados aparte siempre silvania
santiago se sienten como que ha ganado
su vecino no olvidemos que hay un guy de
nació aquí en una ciudad de scranton
aquí estuvo viviendo hasta los 10 años y
ha sido un estado que como sabéis ha
visitado hasta el último momento incluso
el mismo día de las elecciones hemos
podido hablar con algunos de sus
seguidores aquí en esta celebración y
hay una cosa que nos ha llamado la
atención
uno decía ahora ya no me voy a tener que
preocupar de mi seguro médico una de las
cosas que precisamente puso ayer yo
wyden encima de la mesa en esos cuatro
puntos tan importantes de su agenda
política que era precisamente hacer
frente a esa pandemia que atraviesa al
país que ya se ha llevado por delante la
vida de 230 mil personas y lo primero
que va a hacer va a ser poner un plan
encima de la mesa para evitar que más
gente siga muriendo importante también
la economía también importante el medio
ambiente y el racismo esa hora de
protestas de costa a costa del país que
tiene completamente polarizada a la
población no poner una votación la
polarización que hemos visto también
reflejada en las urnas como decías yo
bailé se ha llevado el 74 millones de
votos frente a donald trump o 70
millones muy por encima mucho mejor de
lo que auguraban las encuestas